[Music]
let's go to johnny in chicago what's up
brother johnny how we doing
uh good thank you for taking my call you
got it man thanks for calling what's up
how can i help
well my wife and i are not entirely on
the same page financially
we started following the baby steps of
last year
in november it's causing a lot of fights
she's very davis
um it's hard to
discuss anything with money she gets
irritated very quickly
i know we need marriage counseling we've
been married 22 years
there are some issues that are
um that have to be addressed um but as
far as these baby steps
you know i'm not i just don't feel
willing to take on any more debt
we're about 169 000 in debt mostly
student loans
um and i'm not worried that we can't pay
this off we can be done with this in two
to three years easy we make really good
money but uh she's not fully on board
and she wants to try to buy a house soon
that's not getting into that kind of
debt yeah so for people listening baby
steps talking about
dave ramsey who's my friend he's my boss
too um
the get out of debt plan um
and
johnny and your wife been married 22
years
what made you decide like what made you
look in the mirror and go whoa we owe
169
thousand dollars we got to get out of
this thing what what when did you
discover that
um well
i i'm almost 50. okay and i have a
chronic health issue nothing that seems
that's going to take my life early but
it's an expensive medication
and you know i have children and um i
you know i just want to leave things in
order uh what do you do for like family
and stuff um i'm in health club i'll
leave it a buck um i don't want to say
too much that's all good my wife is also
in healthcare we combined make about uh
just under 200 000 a year okay
um
this has nothing to do with money
you know that
yes i do okay i do
yeah
the main thing i wanted to ask is i know
we need a marriage counselor but my
question is if most people are normal
a marriage counselor might be normal too
right and i don't want him pacifying
some of the things we're trying to
accomplish financially you know yeah
it's it's
it's not about money dude yeah there's a
power
problem in your marriage
there's a strength a
lack of
connection there's a lack of common
purpose
you all are at war and money is the
battleground right now
but a counselors
they don't the counselors shouldn't care
what your goals are they should care
that you know what your goals are and
i'm going to help you connect with one
another as you all achieve these goals
whatever they happen to be
and
your wife
there's a lack of vision here
there's a
you have different fears than she does
and often i hear and i don't want to
over gender this but often i hear
men try to solve a problem like here's a
debt problem we need to have a plan to
get out of that problem and you need to
whoever you is kids spouse whoever you
need to follow this plan
and i got somebody else on the other
side of that thing saying
i want to be safe i am scared of you i'm
tired of you walking in and telling me
how i'm going to do my life because i'm
smart too
and
i'm going to i'll end up putting my
heels in the ground over this issue
because it's not about the money it's
about
i'm sick of you just dragging us around
with whatever new plan new idea new
whatever i may be way out to lunch here
man but
this has nothing to do with money this
has to do with common shared vision
i agree what
you said you want to leave your family
with things in order that you have a
chronic health issue that's expensive
and so you feel this pressure to set up
your family
so far you've told me your wife
she wants a home
so y'all got two competing things here
you want safety and for you safety looks
like x and she wants safety and safety
looks like why
and what you got to do here brother is
stop flexing and stop being like this is
the way it's gotta be and more say
like
what are we gonna i'm almost you're 50
almost 50.
yeah like what's it gonna look like when
we're 16 let's reverse engineer that
back
and you telling her
not we got to get out of debt we gotta
it's this debt scares me
that i'm gonna leave you i'm gonna die
and i'm gonna leave you with this and i
can't be a part of that
yeah you know john the the difficulty i
have is i i'm a very
um
i'm type of person that i like to talk
do i like to get into details yep i'm
always inviting her to have these
conversations these deep conversations
because that's just my personality
that's right okay i never tell her what
to do at all i say let's let's get
together and talk about it let's unwrap
this
but this is just my own opinion here i
believe she has very low
emotional iq and she has anger issues so
if i even broach any topic of anything
to try to better either our
relationships money whatever it is
she gets very defensive and very upset
and if i don't let it go after a minute
or two she'll resort to name calling
things of this nature okay that's fair
so it's very hard to
even to to bring up like the last few
days i've been struggling thinking how
am i gonna suggest we go see a marriage
counselor she's gonna say nothing's
wrong wrong or you're the problem or
you know so i even have a problem with
that so
you gotta control what you can control
you're the only per you go see a
counselor
and here's if i'm you here's exactly
what i would say to my wife
i would say
i
i have for some reason i have created a
world where you don't feel safe having a
deep conversation with me
i have not created a world where my wife
feels safe planning for the future
together
and i am not able to fully articulate
how terrified and scared i am of all
this debt
and i'm gonna go see a counselor so i
can learn some new language
because i'm not doing a good job
communicating how much i love you and
how terrified i am for our future
and the future of our kids and here's
the thing brother that's gonna feel like
you're caving in like i'm submitting i'm
tapping out
yeah dude you gotta get over that's ego
crap talking
all right and otherwise you're gonna try
to force your like what's the right
thing to say to her you've already
answered that question there's nothing
you can say to her you already know what
that is what's gonna happen and so you
can make yourself stone crazy
both psychologically and biochemically
you're gonna i feel that yeah your blood
pressure gonna go up you're gonna have
just
adrenaline and cortisol pulsing through
your veins all day every day your
brain's gonna be anxious and anxious and
anxious until it finally shuts off and
you're gonna go into a season of
depressing and then you're gonna go back
up to anxiety over and over again
you can do all that
or you can make peace with i know what
she's gonna say period
now what now what do i do okay now i'm
gonna take care of me
and i'm gonna make sure that when
i'm ready to have this hard conversation
i'm gonna be all in
okay
and
it is fair to say we're not taking on
any more debt right now
and that
that becomes a boundary issue
yeah yeah that's that's that's going to
be hard
it is it is and you may it it meant your
house may become hell over it
but at some point you guys she already
drew that she already drew the line in
the sand she said if come next year
uh we don't get a house that she would
eat and buy a house on her own okay so
do you listen you're you're
this has nothing to do with money
yeah
and how long have you all been married
22 years together 25.
there's man i'm telling you there's
something else here big
yeah
and my guess is she has told you over
and over for year after year after year
of a thing she wants of a thing she's
interested in
of a
and she finally says enough's enough and
here's the deal man
you gotta lean up she just put a
boundary down
yeah
and either she's she's bluffing
you're gonna call that bluff
um
because what i heard her say is i'm
leaving you
yeah um you know the
we had a house but because of my health
issue i had to change careers yep make
adjustments for it so we sold our house
and we downgraded and that was hard
because we were there for about 15 years
yeah she lost her home she lost her
community and yep
she said for better or worse yeah now
she's getting to find out what worse is
like and here's where this is gonna be
really hard man
yeah
sometimes people leave people with
chronic health conditions
yeah yeah
is that happening to you
um
no i don't the the health issue isn't
such that that she would leave over that
no no it's not it may not be the health
issue but it's the peripheral life that
we all lead now
we can't go on this vacation because i
gotta have this medication or i gotta
sleep this much or we gotta sell this
house and live in an apartment and
it may be that i don't want that life
yeah we were
we've been renting for about three years
and she knew that it was gonna just be
um
for about
five years
until our son finished uh high school
and
um
you know we were just slowly saved but
then that's in that process i discovered
dave yeah i learned a faster way to get
at that yep so i you know i try to
invite her into it try to share with her
i don't make her do it i say you know we
got to do this together yep and so she's
learning to only do so much so so i want
you to not just focus on doing this plan
together
yeah i want you all to focus on doing
the rest of your life together
and what is our new reality
who are we going to be when our son goes
to college
is living in chicago our place for the
rest of our lives could we go do health
care in another city that's got better
um that's got a better cost of living
that the pace is different that we can
get a house sooner or
here's here's a path to a home
if we work like crazy and work overtime
like bonkers
we can be out of debt in 18 months
and then we get one more year of saving
saving saving and then we're going to go
buy a house
but here's the path to where we want to
go and here's the right smart way to do
it and by the way buying a house right
now we're 170 000 in debt in the most
bonkers housing market of our lifetimes
is clinically insane
clinically insane don't do it
but hear me say brother it's not about
the plan this isn't about money
this is about a wife that says i'm about
i had enough of you
for whatever reason
i've about had enough of this
interaction
and i've drawn a big line right here and
you can only control you
so i want you to tell her dude i'm sorry
i have for some reason i haven't made
you safe
i've made you feel safe i've made you
feel loved i've made you feel heard i'm
gonna go see a counselor i would love it
if you join me i would love it if you
join me
because we got 10 15 20 30 years left
together 40 years left together and i
want them to be amazing
and something i'm bringing to the table
isn't working
if she says forget you nothing wrong
great cool awesome
i'm gonna go for me
i'm gonna go for us
that's the best you can do my brother
control your thoughts and your behaviors
and your actions that's about it
we're rooting for you my man hey uh
austin stay on the line johnny we're
gonna give you a
free year subscription to ramsey plus
that's all the financial piece classes
that is all of
the videos all every it's the every
dollar app i'm gonna give it to you for
free for a year this is an expensive
gift merry christmas
it's gonna give you all the stuff but
by taking this you promise you will go
call a counselor for you
you'll go deal with you
okay merry christmas we're rooting for
you brother